this is a colt 1911 yeah you'll see no
there's no see there's no numbers on it
Cody Wilson has a vision of a future
without gun control pri
mark an 3d print a pistol at home or
privately build their own semi-automatic
rifle lethal untraceable unregulated
weapons and now that vision is one step
closer to reality after years of
fighting the US government in court
Wilson just won the right to publish
downloadable schematics for just about
any commercially available firearm
online this is the direct material and
visual expansion of the right to keep
him around five years ago Wilson's
organization defense distributed
released plans for the world's first 3d
printable gun they called it the
Liberator but just days after the group
posted those files the State Department
demanded that they be removed for
violating weapons export controls
defense distributed complied but then
filed a lawsuit claiming it's right to
publish gun files was a form of
protected free speech we said no we're
Americans Americans have the right axis
is data
unquestionably and that the Internet is
now the Commons in a way that libraries
and things were in the past now the
group has essentially won its case its
settlement with the State Department
will allow it to once again upload gun
files designed for DIY gunsmiths and
promises to open the door for others to
do the same is it the end of gun control
like I think it is an essential sense
it's not quite that simple for now
homemade weapons have been involved in
at least two mass shootings in the last
five years but they represent just a
fraction of the wider gun control debate
in America when criminals and dangerous
people are able to create their own guns
in their homes it will become a issue in
the near future Wilson sees his project
as a trump card against the gun control
movement that's intensified in the wake
of February's Parkland school shooting
they left 17 people dead the fence
distributed is using its legal wind to
launch what it hopes will become the
Internet's most comprehensive repository
of digital gun files and as digital
fabrication tools like 3d printers and
computer-controlled milling machines
become cheaper and more than
the fence distributed hopes to unlock a
new generation of DIY gunsmithing beyond
all regulation you cannot regulate the
digital material of guns anymore it's
out there the floods there everyone's
got it we translated our culture into
the 21st century it's here it's going to
grow the group already makes themselves
its own milling machine called the ghost
gunner that can produce frames for
ar-15s and 1911 handguns three years ago
I tried out that machine and easily
built a working air 15 in Wired's office
it's untraceable I didn't have to go
through a background check or any sort
of waiting period to get it the
government has no knowledge of its
existence
Wilson recently gave me a tour of
defense distributed Austin headquarters
Gus Connor is a desktop milling machine
people have such a demand to make
private rifles of private firearms and
sells guns with no numbers then we built
an application you know purpose-made to
help you do that
neither the State Department nor the
Department of Justice would comment on
the settlements the Wilson sees it as
the next chapter in his anarchist
open-source firearms playbook it's
almost like we're creating a platform
for a new propulsive force in our
movement the company is digitizing as
many guns as possible by taking analog
measurements of weapon parts with gauges
and a massive 30 year old machine called
an optical comparator the device
projects an object's image onto a screen
where it's magnified up to a hundred
times that allows the operator to map
out points across a component like this
AR 9 frame in calculates the geometry of
every tiny feature of the gun it's all a
lot of handwork we come over here and we
put the dimensions into a CAD model
we're going to do a lot of starting from
scratch as we build and now they can
legally publish those materials online
of course the database will also make
those blueprints available to people who
can't legally buy guns today minors
felons and the mentally ill who might
now be able to make them at home
Wilson argues that's unlikely to happen
but says the possibility won't stop him
from doing his work I'm resolved that
because of my political principles and
because my
what's driving the project that you have
to accept that obviously people will do
bad things this is not in any way a
justification for a wholesale
class-based prohibition on access to the
right to keep him down Wilson sees a
digital library of weapons material his
group is building as a way to undermine
any future efforts to control the
weapons he believes everyone should have
access to as Wilson admits it's a
dangerous vision I think almost without
exception that people have a right to to
this kind of data regarding anything and
now it has the legal approval of the US
government
[Music]